I don't think it's like alright now we
got into office and now we're just gonna
have the security state beefed up
because screw those civil libertarians
you know it's not that it's I mean he is
a constitutional law professor and these
are things he will be civil liberties
and privacy to things he believes in
deeply when then-senator Barack Obama
needed a speechwriter to capture the
soaring spirit of his 2004 convention
speech and launch him to the presidency
he tapped 24-year old Jon Favreau the
wunderkind political messenger whom
Obama calls his mind-reader became one
of the president's most valued
confidants and from 2005 to 2013 the
chief architect of his most famous
speeches that while we breathe we hope
fads as he's known to the president has
been listed as one of times 100 most
influential people in the world and
gqueues 50 most powerful people in
Washington he currently co-hosts the
podcast keeping at 1600 and writes a
political column for the wringer and he
was a speaker at last weekend's Politico
the calm account of politics recent TV
sat down with Favreau to discuss Trump's
approach to messaging why he now
supports Hillary after attacking her in
2008 how the libertarian party can
appeal to voters and whether Obama's
presidency has lived up to the lofty
promises and inspiring rhetoric that
Favreau crafted
so since you're an expert in political
messaging I thought we'd start with the
current election sure is there's a lot
of retro voice who do you think is a
better communicator Donald Trump or
Hillary Clinton I think Hillary is the
reason I think Trump is such a poor
communicator as he's not disciplined
enough to carry a message that could be
effective against Hillary Clinton so if
you were forced to be his speechwriter
listen and he got on message
how would you reach a pizz
communications to make him more broadly
appealing I mean look I think I would I
mean the central message that could work
for him right is that he represents
change and Hillary doesn't and he would
have to talk about you know bring in a
fresh perspective to Washington and
someone who was a business leader like
he could have a much toned down version
of what he's doing now and be effective
I just don't think he'll ever I don't
think he has the capacity to go there
representing change against Hillary that
sounds familiar what we did yes are you
supporting Hillary in the in this lamp
yes so you're also you know very good at
attacking Hillary which we saw in Frank
o eight what do you see as her biggest
liabilities this time around and if you
were to go after her this election cycle
how would you approach that it's funny
and adding a 2008 we campaigned against
her as someone who was too cautious and
sort of had been in Washington for a
long time and didn't really represent
changed all that kind of stuff and you
know you do that on a campaign and you
sort of get in your own bubble and you
start to really dislike the other side
and you think all these horrible things
about them and then I worked with you
know I got to see her in action in the
White House and I realize that a lot of
the caricatures we painted of her didn't
hold up to reality and so I think that
she is you know I'm I feel great about
my support for Hillary Clinton I think
that she's gonna be she's gonna carry on
the Obama legacy in a big way you know
one of the frequent criticisms that she
leveled against Obama and no way it was
you know the idea of the 3:00 a.m. call
right she's more experienced who you
want picking up the phone at 3:00 a.m.
didn't work last time do you think she
can pull that off this yeah I think so I
think anyone to pull that off against
Trump
because it's it's temperament more than
it is experience I think that experience
is probably a little bit overrated he
does not look in temperament like
someone who should be you know she
should be sitting in the Oval Office
with his hand on the button his finger
on the button
he just doesn't he doesn't he doesn't
come off like that he doesn't come off
like that to Democrats he doesn't come
off like that to independence he doesn't
come off like that's a lot Republicans
they had the right idea trying to get
him on a prompter doing prepared
speeches but you know the per the
prepared speech and a prompter he did
after Orlando was completely insane what
is it like to kind of respond to a
national tragedy like that or a
terrorist attack yeah you know as a
speechwriter when you're in a
responsibility of governing you have to
take time to learn all the facts before
you start making pronouncements so the
first statement the president made about
Orlando he didn't say he didn't mention
Isis well it's because even though news
reports had said the guy pledged
allegiance to Isis the FBI still hadn't
confirmed that and they also knew they'd
find out later that in addition to Isis
he said he yeah he talked about
Hezbollah which is warring with Isis and
those are enough brothers who are
responsible for the Boston Marathon
bombing so you you need to get a full
accounting of the facts before you speak
and that's not always emotionally
satisfying for people who just want all
the answers immediately and he recently
gave a speech in which he explicitly
addressed Trump's attack on him that he
doesn't use the term right yeah well
Islam who did
why did you kind of avoid that term or
did you did you consciously it was I I
remember there are speeches that he gave
in the campaign in 2008 where I think we
used a version of the term radical Islam
this was him getting to the White House
and the best minds in foreign policy
national security said this phrase hurts
our efforts on the ground more than it
helps them because we have Arab allies
that have skin in the game that have
troops on the ground trying to fight
Isis with us and they're telling us if
this looks like a war between the west
and Islam it's going to hurt our efforts
and it's gonna hurt our efforts to get
Arab allies on board in fighting this
terrorist threat
and so you say okay well if all I have
to do to help that is just not use this
term sure and it was to think it was as
simple as that when you're in the room
thinking about it and I don't know that
anyone was like well if you don't say it
though you're gonna get all this [ __ ]
from everyone on the right that you
don't know what the threat there's a lot
of criticism of Trump for stoking these
kind of group identity politics
specifically against you know Mexicans
and Muslims but you could say that you
know the expansion of the drone program
has led to more hatred of America the
lack of closing of Guantanamo then that
type of rhetoric do you think that
that's a valid argument yeah well look
when there's when there's civilian
casualties somewhere that's that's not
going to engender a better view of
America
I think it's constantly a balance
between going after a lot of these
terrors and also making taking great
care to as you as any president has done
in any war forever long before drones to
limit civilian casualties wherever you
can have you been following the
Libertarian Party a little bit
I followed the Convention which sounded
pretty and of course I was interesting
me because bill weld used to be my
governor from Massachusetts and he was a
very beloved governor of Massachusetts
what do you think of their messaging I
think the opportunity has is there for
them because Trump is so intensely
disliked Hillary doesn't have great
favorability ratings either so I think
there's an opportunity for them and then
they have to just decide what is their
message what do they want people to hear
because various parts of the libertarian
message appeal to various parts of the
electorate I think when you get the
things like oh we don't want the you
know on the extremes we don't have the
government involved in licenses right
like driver's license I don't think
that's gonna find a big reception in the
general electorate but I think there's
parts of the message that people would
you know probably be drawn to let's talk
about your time with President Obama
sure were there instances where you
really disagreed with a policy or an
approach that you had to write about
it's funny it's the most common question
I get and I don't know if it was just
because I was in the bubble and a
complete Obama kool-aid drink or maybe
that was it but the substance of all the
policies
I was I was with him but so then and you
know as a candidate do you think that he
over promised no I never I don't because
I think the role of a leader is to hold
up our ideals as a country and the
ideals that we've had for 200 plus years
and say that's our North Star that's
what we need to get to and we might not
get there in my presidency we might not
get there in the next presidency but if
we can move towards that goal and make
some progress inch by inch and we'll
have succeeded in our time but isn't
there a difference between having you
know that North Star and that kind of
inspiring approach and things like you
know I'm gonna close Guantanamo in my
first year I'm gonna reign in the bush
surveillance programs this is gonna be
the most transparent administration in
history yeah what do you think that he
over promised on it look he's sir I'm
een Guantanamo is a great example he
said he's gonna close the cantata
cantata mo Guantanamo he he tried
Congress wouldn't let him he doesn't
have the votes
he could have expended more political
capital on that right this first year
was mainly devoted to the code of EAC
and I think if you had no look I think
if you asked him was it more important
to devote your time to the financial
crisis and devote your political capital
to passing the Recovery Act and the auto
bailout and all this other stand the
financial bailout all those kind of
stuff versus Guantanamo he would say
okay this is a horrible this is a tough
decision but I'd rather expendable
capital on on the economy and I also
think that there's the reality of
Congress the Congress you have in this
Congress that decided not to agree with
him on anything especially the
Republicans no matter how much political
capital you expend I don't think it was
an issue I don't think one time was an H
issue of him expending more capital or
less capital I think it's an issue of
the Republicans have said they're gonna
dig in that they have the votes to stop
them and that's that's it but at the
same time like the ACA that passed
without a single Republican vote you
know there was a massive massive
opposition to that there are Republicans
who support closing Guantanamo many more
than health care so why don't I think I
think you probably probably can't get
enough Democrats on board there to I
don't know the exact I don't know the
exact votes on that but I know that
every day the president has woken up and
wanting to win but and wanted to close
Guantanamo he probably does to this day
and what about the things that were kind
of squarely in his domain like
surveillance program
he you know ran look or tail bush I
think on national security it becomes
very difficult to balance civil
liberties and privacy with security I
think that is a constant battle that
every president has to engage in every
single day and I'd like I said I think
sometimes sometimes you make good
decisions and sometimes you could have
made better decisions do you think that
he should have made better decisions in
that area I'd let say I don't I didn't
get all the Intel briefing so I don't
see all the I don't see all the threats
that are facing us but knowing those
guys I don't think they're made because
it's like all right now we got into
office and now we're just gonna have the
security state beefed up because screw
those civil libertarians you know it's
not that it's I mean he is a
constitutional law professor and these
are things he believed civil liberties
and privacy or things he believes in
deeply but he also has this
responsibility as commander-in-chief to
keep us safe you know that's the
argument that George W Bush made right
like the resident knows things you don't
know Obama saw that he was
constitutional law professor he said you
know there are certain principles that
we don't break the Fourth Amendment we
respect people's right to privacy and
then he expanded the programs and we do
know that prism and these other
surveillance programs have never failed
a terrorist plot that was kind of the
bedrock of his campaign and you had a
big role in shaping that so do you do
you still think that he did the right
thing look I think that he has been
trying to make reforms over the last
eight years and I think you need more
you know judicial oversight on all of
this stuff and I think that's one way to
do it but at some point you know someone
has to be watching the Watchers right
but I I think you do need Watchers I
think you think you do because I think
these and and I think that's it there
are a lot of plots that have been foiled
and so I think that whoever the next
president is continuing to make sure
that there are safeguards in place that
if a Donald Trump became president he
couldn't he didn't he doesn't have the
executive authority to suddenly create a
police surveillance state that has no
checks on it whatsoever I think that's
very important so you wouldn't want
Donald Trump to have a killed
right but Obama he's no look I think I I
think that you need we need safeguards
in place and I think that the judiciary
is one place to do I think judiciary's
probably the only place to do that
because I don't think you can open
everything up to the public because you
just you can't you can't have on
national security all the time
full transparency but also at you know
on transparency that was another bedrock
he can't pay a principle right big price
transparent administration and during
his administration he's prosecuted more
whistleblowers than any other previous
administration the number of classified
documents has exploded where do you
think he went off the rails in that
respect only thing I only I think I
would say is and I I'm only saying this
because my friends who've worked in the
National Security decided to say it I
don't know enough to comment out of it
as much but over-classification is a
huge problem too many things are
classified just because and I think the
president has recognized that problem as
well so I think that's something that
need to do the whistleblower thing I
have to say when you sign up and you
decide that you're going to be part of
the federal government especially if you
get a security clearance they tell you
if you leak information it is a severe
penalty and and very very illegal and if
you don't want to and if you feel like
your conscious is gonna stop you then
don't sign up and don't get your
security clearance and go find another
job those people have to be prosecuted
because it's part of the law and so this
whole thing so far journalists haven't
been prosecuted about this right the
people who were the administration has
gone after the people who have broken
the law by leaking highly sensitive
national security information but they
were tapping journalists phones and I
mean there you know there was though
like Eric Holder subpoenaed records from
journalists and I mean well you can't
deny that he has no because one of any
other press once you get well there's
just been more there's just been more
leaks that's why you know like I don't
there's I'm for sure the President did
not walk in and say I got a clamp down
on all these whistleblowers it's just
the case has come to the Justice
Department because someone broke the law
and there was a leak and sensitive
classified information and we have to
have an investigation and part of the
investigation is they told this
journalist right so then that's when
records are subpoenaed and all
you know I think it is fair that you say
that there's this law you break the law
you should be prosecuted but at the same
time you know everybody's they're sworn
to uphold the Constitution as well and
you have somebody like Thomas Drake who
tried you know numerous numerous times
going up the chain wasn't taken
seriously and that's when he went to the
press same thing you know Edward Snowden
he claims that he went up the chain
several times yeah so do you think that
there's any role for civil disobedience
when you are convinced that the
Constitution is being violated which has
now been affirmed by federal courts
right and nobody's doing anything about
it look I think that's a tough I think
that's a tough question I think in some
I guess I would answer it I don't know I
mean I think that I think there's a role
for I do think there's a role for civil
disobedience of course and I think
there's a role for whistleblowers in our
society of course but I do think that
there are there are also you know like I
said there's a lot so there's laws in
the book and there are roles for there
is a role for civil disobedience and
beyond that like I don't I don't know
enough about every single case to be
spouting off left and right but I the
point is well-taken but you think he's
generally unbalanced rooted ideally I
don't yeah another thing that you've
talked about the reason that you really
liked working with Obama is because he
seemed like a more authentic kind of
honest politician you point out injuries
from my father he wrote about his drug
use and his struggles as a young man
another way to view that is that there
are still people whose lives are being
ruined particularly young black men who
were the same age as he was when he was
using drugs he got into power he did
nothing to change the war on drugs there
that's still happening today so why do
you view that as a good thing that he
admitted to that you know you can make
the argument that that's not authentic I
think he has done I mean I think that he
reduced the disparity between crack
cocaine and powder cocaine sentencing I
think he's been working on recidivism
issues and you know first president I go
to a federal prison to talk about car
serration and I think that the Attorney
General has I mean that they're the
prosecution's of people with marijuana
has gone down and sort of the Justice
Department hasn't really gone after that
so I do think you can say on
in terms of you know locking up people
and stuff like that that there's been
some progress although a nun marijuana I
mean that was you know that was a big
another campaign promise he said that he
was not gonna use DOJ resources to go
after states that have legalized it and
then he spent twice as much as Bush
doing rates of medical marijuana
facilities raided many more so how do
you how do you reconcile that
I mean Colorado has a thriving business
right now that the DOJ has not has not
touched that's you know so I think
that's just like that's the last you
know two years right I'm talking with
you first six law that you got you I
mean like I said you become president
and you've got a whole first of all he
can't be bossing around the DOJ all the
time because they're independent and so
I think you know they sort of came to
that they came to that over over six
years and we're making progress do you
think that there's anything else that
you'd like to see him do to rein in the
war on drugs right and surveillance you
know I think there's like I said I'm not
I'm not experts in those topics so I
should not off about all the different
policies but I'm sure I'm sure what I
know for sure is there's a lot more that
the next president can do and you know I
don't know if he can do it in his last
couple months to make sure that you know
we are not putting tons of people in
prison for their whole lives for very
small nonviolent offenses and I also
think there's a lot to be done still on
making sure that we can protect this
country and still protect people's civil
liberties and their privacy I absolutely
think there's more to be done about
those issues all right well thank you so
much for thank you I appreciate it
freezin TV I'm Justin Monticello